il ya eu toutes les phrases cultes et ça
a été un festival c'est vrai que encore
une fois on découvrait un truisme pas
moi mais les gens qui nous regardent et
les parents découvrez comment les jeunes
parlait alors des fois c'est français je
n'ai pas détourné parfois parfois ça
l'est beaucoup moins regardés
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est il apprécie faire
l'amour au temps du même coup bouffer le
must c'est faire l'amour ou pantois
fabrice m'a énormément énormément déçu
je trouve qu'il a plutôt qu'une
personnalité c'est plus fabrice et
jean-edouard de la bible en fait dit on
la saq l'honneur je viens là ta gueule
en train de super fille je peux
également sur les trottoirs et sont
dépendants de foot mais les graves
j'ai la porte à leur [ __ ] j'ai
toujours voulu mettre les ballons de
basket sur les aime portement sur l'aîné
a été tellement conne et hypocrite
rigola qu'il a annoncé viser carrément
tombé sur le meilleur fois rien à dire
j'ai senti de loin j'ai senti la grosse
merde on a senti le meilleur toujours
moi toujours animé par le chien ou le
playboy mais toujours toujours toujours
pour moi une sorte d'être en scène pour
avoir les poches
non ça c'est ce qui fait peut-être trop
charmant situation et regarde par
exemple les gens en jean edouard et beau
ouais c'est vrai il n'ya pas de il n'a
pas de charme
ce que j'ai remarqué auparavant il ya
une beauté froide et moi la beauté
froide supporte pas les gens comme jean
edouard je le reverrai pas parce que je
le trouve très hypocrite par contre que
ces sourires de playboy à de man il peut
s'énerver vois pas ce que je veux dire
stevie trouve que c'est pas normal qu'on
ait dit que doit être sûrement 2010 or
la gueule alors à toi de dormir dit rien
j'aime essayer de l'aider et par mois
franchement moins gros des conquois
c'est clair quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais noir il est beau mais bon c'est
encore ce nom mais c'est affreux parce
qu'en fait on revoit des emails mais ça
nous fait pleurer de rire parce que tu
avais tort en fait ouais voilà ça fait
mal quand je vois comment la femme
formidable avec laquelle a été marié
aujourd'hui je te dis que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]